on peut filmer les gens à leur insu
éventuellement et donc quand on est un
homme qui veut devenir président de la
république c'est quand même très qu'elle
voulait devenir président pas c'est une
vraie question là vous posez une station
ce qui vous laisse je l'ait vraiment
venez de venir préciser une vraie
question sert que ses amis ne voulait
parfois plus tant que lui-même mais ça
on a beaucoup poussé à y aller il avait
la dimension intellectuelle
il avait un moment donné la carrure la
gela tout semblait concourir à ce qu'il
devienne président mais ce qui le
voulait lui-même sachant que quand on
est président on peut plus avoir cette
vie qu'il aime lui de mon resto de bonne
chère de soirée amusant de tout ça est
ce que vous ne pensez pas que étant
donné qu'il est devenu extrêmement
dangereux était un instrument de joie il
ya plein de gens qui crient au complot
c'est ça qui va veut dire aussi qu'il ya
un complot parce qu'il était devenu
tellement dangereux et qu'on était
persuadé que c'était le prochain
président qui a eu un complot autour de
lui c'est la thèse aussi qu'on peut
entendre ici et là moi j'ai du mal à
penser qu'il ya eu un complot tel que
les choses se sont déroulées en tout cas
j'ai des sentiments en revanche que à
partir du moment où ils avaient un pied
dans la tombe
on lui a mis les deux pieds la tête et
le reste on là je veux que les gens
n'attendaient que ça en fait bah il ya
un certain en tout cas qui n'attendait
que ça mais faux pas de dominique
strauss kahn et quand c'est arrivé sont
dit on va le vraisemblablement même si
moi de ma mon intime conviction c'est
qu'il n'aurait jamais été président de
rappeler à autre pensée bas regardez
comment ça bah oui parce que je pense
qu'il n'aurait pas passé la primaire il
aurait été battu par françois hollande
lors de la primaire fait des sondages
commençaient dès crois que les cours
commencent à se croiser françois
hollande correspondait beaucoup plus aux
aspirations du peuple de gauche
strauss kahn avec son style de vie avec
ses positions sociales libérales etc
plaisait pas au peuple de gauche
donc ils n'auraient pas passé la
première n'aura pas été président